تسببت الحرب الاسرائيليه في قطاع غزه في
دمار كبير في شبكات الصرف الصحي وادى
القصف الاسرائيلي الى تعطيل عمليات معالجه
مياه الصرف الصحي وتوقف مضخات التصريف
مراسلنا اسماعيل الغول رصد جانبا من هذه
الاضرار في مدينه
غزه يعيش قطاع غزه ازمه بيئيه وكارثه في
ظل تدمير قوات الاحتلال لمضخات مياه الصرف
الصحي وبرك تجميع مياه الامطار نحن الان
في محطه سب به هذه المحطه التي دمرت بفعل
قوات الاحتلال ولم يبقى منها اي شيء
لاعاده تشغيلها بسبب الدمار الكبير الذي
حل في هذا المكان بالاضافه الى وجود حريق
لل المولدات الكهربائيه وتدمير حتى بركه
التجميع الاساسي في داخل هذه المخطه كانت
تستقبل يوميا حوالي 30,000 متر مكعب من
مياه الصرف الصحي وتقوم بضخها من هذا
المكان الى الى محطه المعالجه الرئيسيه في
منطقه الشيخ عجلين كانت هذه البركه تستوعب
حوالي 28000 متر مكعب من مياه الامطار
الان مليئه بمياه الصرف الصحي طفحت مياه
الصرف الصحي اغرقت المكان بشكل كامل
المحيط بالمحطه كما نشاهد هنا الشوارع
غرقت واغرقت بمياه الصرف الصحي الاراضي
الزراعيه هنا كانت بياره كامله من اشجار
البرتقال والحمضيات تم اغراقها بالكامل
كما نشاهد بمياه الصرف الصحي طبعا بعد
تدميرها من الاحتلال وجرافات الاحتلال
ودبابات الاحتلال تم تجريف هذه الاراضي
بشكل كامل من المزروعات والاشجار الموجوده
فيها نقوم الاليا بشكل اني
بتصريف مياه الصرف الصحي من هذا المكان
الى نفق اللي هو نفق الامطار الموجود في
منطقه الزيتون والذي يعبر من شارع صلاح
الدين متجها الى بركه تجميع مياه الامطار
في منطقه الشيخ
رضوان نحن الان في منطقه بركه الشيخ رضوان
هذه البركه المعرضه للفيضان على المناطق
الشرقيه مثل منطقه حي المناره ومنطقه حي
النفق هذه المناطق الان مهدده بشكل حقيقي
من فيضان بركه الشيخ رضوان بسبب ارتفاع
المنسوب الكبير للمياه مياه الامطار
بالتحديد تم تدمير شبكه الكهرباء ومحولات
الكهرباء الرئيسيه بشكل كامل كذلك تم
تدمير مولدات الكهرباء الرئيسيه عدد اثنين
مولد بقدره 1د ميجا لكل مولد لحتى هذه
اللحظه لا نعرف مدى الاضرار التي لحقت
بالخط الناقل للمياه اللي هو يصل ما بين
البركه
الى الى مصب النهائي في في على في البحر
غزه تواجه خطر حقيقي من فيضان هذه البرك
على الاحياء المجاوره بعد تير قوات
الاحتلال لمولدات الصرف الصحي وتشغيل هذه
الابار بشكل فعلي في مختلف
المحطات اسماعيل الغول مدينه غزه
الجزيره